hello freak [ __ ] well so that's
that's where right that's where when you
say like I'm reasonable with a minor
thing well because you have to take into
context other other people right is it
is it a hit job but also what you said
earlier where people are human beings
and and looked like let's talk it out so
Milo said some some things that even he
said he apologized for others he said
was misconstrued but but it's and then
and then there's the George Takei thing
which is different but still the same
when George Takei thing you have to
explain to people because most people
have no idea what you're talking well so
sorry yeah so I this is a problem for me
I have conversations in my head that
then I utter you're just so entrenched
with media there's so much [ __ ] coming
into your head every day they assume
everybody else is watching the same
videos but they're they're just actually
living their loss so they went on they
did a hit piece on George Takei
essentially to sort of show that George
Takei well he was talking about his own
personal experiences when he was very
young with a camp counselor who did some
sexually inappropriate things to him but
he was talking about them in a very
positive way that he enjoyed it and
people are saying George Takei is
promoting sex among 13 year olds as
being okay no he's talking about his own
personal experience and being on write
about it well and then the way that ends
up becoming a comparison is that the
because it ends up being this weird
argument of numbers of lines in the sand
where he said I said 13 because that's
when I had my first experience then we
talked about the the age of China Marie
talked about the age of 14 which was I
think when you were though so that was a
conversation he had with you yes he was
reached yeah right and then people were
pointing out that it's his mindset
changed and my argument there was what
you're talking about to me even if he at
that at any point before before he
acknowledged it to me it sounded like he
was a victim yes and but then that
creates the arguments you of if
someone's a victim early in life what
does that excuse later on now I'm not
making the argument that Milo then went
on to do and and became a Sandusky right
he was having a conversation and it's
words but at what point do we excuse
things and that's just like that's a
conversation I like to have where it's
it's not damning I don't want to go in
on a victim but also at the same time
I'm going it's [ __ ] weird it's a me
and I think it's completely wrong if you
have an adult that's trying to [ __ ] a
thirteen-year-old I think that's
completely wrong like just when you and
I feel like you always have to put
people in in your uh in their shoes
where if I was a parent and I'm dropping
my kid off the [ __ ] middle school and
I find out some 25 year old is [ __ ]
my son that's gonna I'm gonna go to jail
but that's gonna be a [ __ ] dead
person
a dead person 100% that someone's
molesting my child no done yeah I mean I
I completely feel you and I understand
what you're saying I think what the Milo
situation is very bizarre because I
think there is irreparable damage done
to people when they were left stood his
children and I think Milo has been
really clear about the fact that he was
molested and he's tried to paint it in a
positive light but he tries to paint a
lot of fucked-up things in a positive
light and it could easily be his
rationalizing and trying to figure out
yeah no one wants to be a victim in
their life right made it a positive
thing to control him yeah so that's why
I say like let's let's think of it in
that way rather than going he's against
me let's just destroy him well I think
that he says things that Milo does that
I mean he's a merchant of outrage that's
his business and when people get
outraged back at him and if somehow
another sticks like this pedophile stuff
mhm you can't be upset this is the game
that you just started to play if you get
knocked the [ __ ] out you know if you're
Mike Tyson and all sudden you get
knocked out are we supposed to feel bad
for you you've been knocking people out
your whole career right you know this
he's a merchant of outrage if if it's
valid if the outrage is valid and I
think it's valid I think that what
they're saying about what he was saying
is absolutely valid if he says that
there can be incredibly positive
relationships between very young men and
are you're very young boys rather an
older gay men and that this could keep
men from suicide hit the brakes stop no
it's [ __ ] illegal for a reason right
and you could potentially be encouraging
someone who's fence sitting right now
thinking about [ __ ] kids right to hop
right over to the other side and start
doing it because it was positive for my
love it doesn't official it is the
conversation because also to that extent
there might be someone that is 13 that's
being abused that all of a sudden feels
like that's normal
right right so right but let's like
let's talk about it I 100 cent don't
agree with the words it is a tricky
situation because you are talking about
someone that was a victim heinous crime
and then just you know then talking out
talking about it and going from there
but it's also he said that he was gay at
the time he knew he was gay and he was
the sexual predator and every situation
has its own variables right and in his
look he's clearly a damaged guy okay and
I'd like him he's clearly a damaged guy
but the way he lashes out and the way he
gets attention I don't like the the
left's reaction to him I like that far
less than I like what he's saying I feel
like with a guy like Milo he's not doing
any real violent things he's not doing
any real damage and what you should do
is confront him with words yet bait him
you pick apart his arguments about
feminism about transgender people about
gay rights cuz he's got some crazy
writes about he's got some crazy
thoughts about gay people and he's gay
he thinks that it's a choice and he
thinks that it's it's offensive and if
he could have a pill to not be gay he
would take it in a heartbeat like he
said all kinds of crazy [ __ ] I think
when you have someone like Milo or
anyone else the the number one thing
shouldn't be let me silence that person
right because that's just gonna one
bolster them validate them let them talk
right so when you see situations like
like Berkeley where I did see I had
people that sent me videos and there was
like there was a protest in beginning
that it was just people being outspoken
and there's the [ __ ] crazy chaos
people I know you've talked about it
before of like the the people getting
sprayed in the face with [ __ ] pepper
spray people beaten in the streets
obviously I hate those people what what
I really really hate is the the people
that aren't doing that that are like
yeah that's what we should be doing that
aren't doing like you [ __ ] crazy you
think this is a positive
you think this bolsters your argument
that that we're gonna go against what we
don't agree them that they're saying
with [ __ ] violence you think that
makes you the winner that's insane it
straight-up insane well it's also they
put these blanket labels he's a Nazi he
promotes genocide he they say all these
things and they they say these things so
that they can attack well there was no
yeah that whole he's a fascist bunch of
Nazi move
after Richard Spencer got a punched in
the face which once again who's Richard
Spencer our wait wait wait am I getting
the name of wrong
now the the guy that uh what double
check go ahead
you've made me doubt myself now he's
part of uh you might be right
I mean I'm I don't I just don't know who
it is
yeah you always see his face he just got
booted out of Ceefax form I understand
so he's he talks about just look him up
Yakut uh I imagine you aren't gonna be a
fan but people are like he's a literal
Nazi we got to punch these people that
people like overjoyed so he really is a
Nazi people just happy but supremacist
dis guy I don't want to I don't want to
label this guy on it III think that you
you just call himself a white
nationalist or anything like family
that's like that's the website Oh easy
neo Nazi neo-nazi everywhere I don't
know if he calls myself that double
check yeah that's the thing I don't
wanna I don't want to slam a label on
someone and then do that thing right so
it's hard yeah but so he got punched in
the face everyone [ __ ] cheered for it
but the problem is then then they move
then you move the goalposts of who's a
[ __ ] Nazi all of a sudden PewDiePie's
a [ __ ] Nazi ever ever everyone's a
Nazi and we can just be violent punch
Nazis
yeah the punch Nazi thing and and so the
whole thing is just debate these people
right so like just just let them be
their own undoing if they are actually
that wrong
[Music]